[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde nous allons vous parler de
l'éventail du sexe comme le reste des
comportements humains les pratiques
sexuelles évoluent de l'hétérosexualité
à l'homosexualité et au-delà avec la
cyber sexualité les sextoys les sites de
rencontres jusqu'aux approches genrées
transgenré voir une sexualité
transparente dite neutre l'éventail du
sexe se décline sur le mode des plaisirs
des jouissances des fluctuations
identitaires et de la consommation
illimitée avec aussi des dérives
violentes dont les viols de femmes
constituent la face noire de la
sexualité mortifère depuis que le
mouvement MiTo a émergé mais pas que la
parole des femmes c'est libérée pour
dénoncer les violences sexuelles en même
temps que le désir féminin c'est mieux
confirmer libérer d'une tutelle
patriarcale qualifiée parfois de
masculinité toxique voire machiste avec
quel répercussions sur la sexualité des
jeunes générations et la sexualité des
seniors la sexualité est aussi un
marqueur de civilisation qu'il s'agisse
de la répression contre les femmes non
voilées en Iran de l'excision toujours
pratiquée dans les contrées africaines
des entraves à l'avortement dans
certains États américains la liberté
sexuelle s'apparente politiquement au
libre arbitre laissez à chacune et
chacun de jouir de son corps comme bon
lui semble jusqu'où est-ce possible
c'est ce que nous allons voir dans cet
éventail du sexe avec Magali
crozecallisto vous êtes sexologue
psychologue et séistes
vous êtes psychiatre et psychanalyste
Corinne Fortier vous êtes anthropologue
au Collège de France Philippe Bruneau
vous êtes psychiatre anthropologue et
directeur d'études à l'Université de
Paris
[Musique]
alors
commençons avec notre grand poète Artaud
il sépare la sexualité de l'amour dans
le quotidien des choses de la vie on a
tendance à les confondre qui a raison et
qu'en est-il en pratique Philippe Bruno
question qui ne mériterait très très
long débat entre sexualité et amour moi
je dirais qu'à la fois
l'amour et la grande affaire des humains
ça n'existe pas de cette manière dans
l'animalité et d'une certaine façon
c'est l'anthropologue qui voit ce qui
fait c'est tout ce que je recherche
depuis le que je m'occupe de sexualité
qu'est-ce qui est humain dans la
sexualité humaine il y a ce lien
d'attachement de l'amour toutes les
sociétés vont le décliner et puis la
sexualité qui en général dans toutes les
sociétés de la tradition et jusqu'à chez
nous une cinquantaine 70 ans d'années
elle est fortement liée avec la
fécondité nous vivons une période je
vais même presque dire anormal dans une
partie la partie occidentale de
l'humanité c'est c'est moins de 20% dans
lequel nous avons séparé l'amour
jouissance quelquefois et on va dire on
fait l'amour et puis fécondités on peut
très bien avoir une sexualité sans se
reproduire on peut être beaucoup plus
libre donc très difficile de
je dirais l'amour et certainement l'un
des éléments pour moi fondamentaux de
l'humanité la sexualité est un outil qui
peut nous aider aujourd'hui à nous
épanouir mais qui sert beaucoup à la
fécondité et le gros problème c'est les
modes de pression qui va y avoir
notamment dans les sociétés de la
tradition aujourd'hui avec toujours
cette ce lien qui était sexualité
fécondité parce que dernier mot
la plus grande invention pour moi de
l'histoire de l'humanité c'est tout de
même lorsqu'on a pu séparer cela et
qu'on a qu'à paraît en Occident
l'existence sociale des femmes parce que
l'on peut libérer les femmes d'une
contrainte de la grossesse de
l'enfantement du soin permanent et d'une
certaine façon de l'éviction de
l'univers et de l'espace social alors
l'anthropologue que vous êtes Corinne
Fortier adhère à ce qui vient d'être dit
ou quel lien établissez-vous peut-être
me référer à ce qui était dit avant déjà
l'amour ça peut exister il y a l'amour
maternel par exemple qui est justement
où il y a des prohibitions de l'inceste
et puis et donc pas de sexualité en tout
cas permises donc il y a en fait il y a
quelque chose quand on pense à ses
amours qui ne sont pas reliés à un
partenaire sexuel on peut avoir déjà un
des amours qui sont sans sexualité et
même où la sexualité est prohibée donc
c'est un sentiment affectif où il y a
pas nécessairement de de rapports
sexuels qui lui corrélatif mais en effet
les sociétés visant à la reproduction à
la reproduction de d'elle-même enfin de
la société qui passe par une
reproduction physique il y a donc la
nécessité d'avoir une sexualité
procréative et qui est relier à un amour
conjugal or aussi le sentiment amoureux
conjugal il peut faire le sentiment
amoureux il peut aussi se développer en
dehors de la conjugalité mais donc
toutes les sociétés visent à idéaliser
l'amour conjugal pour aussi que il y ait
à l'intérieur de ce couple qui est
légitime une sexualité
reproductrice reproductive
essentiellement donc bien sûr que les
les deux sont liés socialement je dirais
aussi qu'il y a une approche dans nos
sociétés et ailleurs il y a une approche
j'en Ré ou souvent les femmes pensent
plus que la question de la sexualité
enfin qu'il faut être amoureux pour
avoir des rapports sexuels on va rentrer
dans le détail du côté des hommes pour
vous Magalie Crozet Callisto sur le lien
amour et sexualité oui je partage tout à
fait ce que ce que vous venez de dire
aussi c'est-à-dire qu'on voit que le
sexe est un est un outil et la visée le
but du chemin est encore l'amour et dans
toutes les les grandes enquêtes qui ont
été faites ces dernières années et
Philippe Renaud en a parlé longuement
dans ses livres aussi on voit que cette
image se mythe du prince charmant perdu
dans notre société et de la bonne épouse
etc donc les stéréotypes font de la
résistance on est encore dans des dans
des clichés bien ancrés et normés sauf
que les jeunes générations notamment Y
et Z sont en train de venir nous
questionner sur ces schémas sur ses
scripts sexuels parce qu'on voit que la
sexualité n'est pas vécue de la même
manière
actuellement par les jeunes générations
notamment parce que vous avez tout à
l'heure appelé la sexualité neutre on
peut parler aussi de l apostrophe la
sexualité en un seul mot qui arrive de
plus en plus sur le devant de la scène
aujourd'hui alors très bien leur marque
Strauss quand même dans la citation il y
avait quand même le fait que une
dimension plus universelle il dit que ce
qui sépare c'est la sexualité et ce qui
unit c'est l'amour qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez moi je souscris et je suis
d'accord avec ce qui vient d'être dit
aussi mais la sexualité est un carrefour
est une construction en fait c'est ce
que nous a appris Freud est une
construction qui d'une part
effectivement relève de l'aspiration à
l'un dans l'amour et d'autre part et
l'expression de la pulsion et entre les
deux et bien ça coince toujours ça ne
marche jamais c'est ce qui fait la
difficulté de la sexualité de la
sexualité pour tout le monde pour tout
le monde avec tous les symptômes sexuels
et l'intérêt que nous portons à la
sexualité parce que là c'est un domaine
où nous sommes sûrs on en aura jamais le
dernier mot
voulait dire que l'amour est un
sentiment universel et la sexualité un
bricolage technique
montage pulsionnel bricolage technique
absolument oui absolument c'est la
position de Freud très explicite et
c'est la vôtre oui et c'est la oui
Magalie et ça renvoie cette citation de
Freud qui on voit bien en cabinet de
consultation les hommes qui viennent
consulter parce qu'il n'éprouve plus
forcément de désir pour leur campagne ou
leur épouse et freud disait déjà quand
ils aiment ils ne désirent pas et quand
ils désirent il n'aime pas donc il
mettait déjà en miroir sexualité et
amour avec toute le questionnement de la
les hommes les confondre spécialement
difficiles plus difficiles peut-être que
pour les femmes alors essayons d'aller
plus loin au moins pour les sociétés
démocratiques ce que nous sommes la
législation dans le domaine de la
sexualité
avance au rythme de l'évolution des
opinions publiques tout ou presque si on
exclut les violences sexuelles et le
viol est aujourd'hui permis qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de émancipation sans
limite de la sexualité Magali Crozet
Callisto alors je dirais pas que tout
est absolument permis dans notre société
aujourd'hui parce que dit tout sauf le
viol et la violence sexuelle oui mais
enfin pas mal de femmes disent encore
que si elle vivent une sexualité libre
il y a ce regard social qui apparaît
pour et qu'il est stigmatise comme des
femmes des wergondées et je vous passe
d'autres d'autres termes donc c'est
encore pas si simple que ça d'avoir une
sexualité
égalitaire dans les comportements entre
les hommes et les femmes dans notre dans
notre société par contre ce qu'on voit
j'ai eu l'occasion de faire une petite
étude à travers le cinéma des évolutions
de l'orgasme du début du 20e siècle
jusqu'à aujourd'hui on voit qu'il y a eu
au fur et à mesure des années une
sexualité tout d'abord métaphorisée
exemple le film de Renoir une partie de
campagne tirée de en repassant qui au
moment de l'orgasme présentait l'animal
le rossignol comme la métaphore de
l'orgasme on retrouve ça dans d'autres
films Les Amants Louis mal les masses
s'attachent sans là c'est une formidable
où on voit le premier orgasme d'une
femme au cinéma ensuite les années 70
c'est l'orgasme érotique puis
pornographie avec les années 80-90 on
voit un orgasme prophylactique et
presque violenté avec l'arrivée
notamment du sida et ce qu'on aperçoit
depuis quelques années c'est ce sont des
orgasmes de plus en plus numérisés
comme une évolution d'orgasme c'est
peut-être pas que ça mais pour vous
comment vous définissez l'orgasme
simplement alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est de voir l'histoire de l'orgasme
pour comprendre comment fonctionne une
société mais la bonne définition de
l'orgasme c'est fabuleux cette
définition de l'orgasme parce qu'il y a
un grand paradoxe c'est une mise en
tension
qui demande aussi un lâcher prise c'est
comme appuyer en même temps sur le frein
à l'accélérateur pour trouver le bon
régime qui est même au transport et
concrètement ça veut dire quoi alors
concrètement le trésor la langue
française dit que c'est un état de
gonflement au niveau organique donc des
parties génitales et d'un point de vue
de l'homme et de la femme de l'homme et
de la femme et ça se joue aussi en
parallèle au niveau cérébral avec une
actimisation du système nerveux
notamment du circuit de récompense bon
alors je voudrais savoir Philippe Bruno
est-ce que vous adhérez à cette histoire
de la sexualité qui serait une
succession d'orgasmes alors c'est pas
tout à fait cela que
je reprendrai quelque chose je trouve
vraiment intéressant pour comprendre
l'idée première l'orgasme dans sa son
étymologie grecque
orgasme c'est l'état du fruit mûr qui va
éclater
lorsque on le voit très bien il y a un
jeu qui sort si vous voulez mais ce que
j'allais dire lorsqu'elle évoque cela et
en prenant le l'image par exemple
l'évolution de dans le cinéma c'est très
vrai que la grande libération des idées
en matière de sexualité depuis 70 ans à
peu près les années 70 on a vu venir au
devant de la scène la jouissance et puis
en grande partie maintenant d'orgasmes
parce qu'il a été j'allais dire interdit
aux femmes et là je vais venir dans un
instant mais moi l'évolution que
j'aurais vu dans ces toujours ces 70
années à peu près
moi j'aime bien la dire de cette manière
en parlant de la France c'est pas vrai
de tout l'excident on est quand même un
pays assez libre dans les idées et je
trouvais qu'on est venu à une sorte
d'absence de jugement moral je parle pas
les 10 dernières années mais c'est vrai
que
même dans les années 50 je crois qu'on
devait signaler des comportements qui
sexuellement paraissaient inacceptable
aujourd'hui on est arrivé on est arrivé
à quelque chose qui était très libre à
l'exclusion d'un seul interdit
l'intrusion de la sexualité des adultes
dans celle des enfants je le résume de
cette façon là par contre il y a quelque
chose de très nouveau qui se passe alors
depuis les depuis 20 ans
en grande partie parce que la sexualité
féminine a été beaucoup plus libérée en
1997 lorsque j'écris mon éloge de la
masturbation qui était destiné aux
femmes
il a été reçu surtout par les hommes le
mot masturbation n'existait pas pour les
femmes à l'époque c'est vrai que
qu'est-ce que l'on voit c'est la
libération de la jouissance féminine la
redécouverte de du clitoris ainsi de
suite mais là les nouvelles générations
nous amènent quelque chose d'autre à
nous qui avons connu ces évolutions
différentes et bien on voit de quelle
façon par exemple nous en tant que
psychiatre dans la première année j'ai
été impressionné par le nombre de
témoignages on n'y avait pas été préparé
de femmes c'était essentiellement des
femmes qui parlait d'inceste le hashtag
me to hashtag inceste on fait même s'il
y a des excès tant pis ça le problème on
fait plus en 5 ans aujourd'hui que nos
tentatives depuis 30 ans d'essayer d'en
parler en nous disait oui ça existe dans
certains milieux bien sûr que non c'est
à dire que donc on a une grande
libération qui s'est faite
quelque chose dans les jeunes
générations tant mieux qui fait
bousculer les choses avec peut-être
attention puisque je disais libération
absence de jugement moral c'est vrai
qu'actuellement il peut arriver un
retour au jugement moral tout à fait
alors qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
évolution de la sexualité marche trop
est-ce qu'elle est libération est-ce
qu'elle est consommation est-ce qu'elle
est expression de la jouissance tout
azimut elle se dit libération et
pourquoi pas mais j'ajoute là aussi si
vous permettez à ce que vous venez de
dire la sexualité infantile et la
sexualité infantile elle est traumatique
elle est angoissante elle est sans issue
et il y a d'une part la curiosité
brûlante des enfants sur comment on fait
les enfants qu'elle a différence entre
un garçon et une fille et il y a aussi
l'excitation sexuelle une excitation
sexuelle qui est déclenchée par des
incidents absolument contingents qui
sont pas nécessairement sexuels ou sans
génitaux et comme ça s'imprime un
certain nombre d'images fixes qui vont
déterminer les choix adultes et cette
sexualité infantile elle est elle est et
elle restera honteuse et coupable
toujours
et donc excusez-moi on peut dire
masturbez-vous masturbez-vous
effectivement quand j'étais jeune on
cachait ça la masturbation ça se faisait
en cachette honteusement maintenant
c'est c'est admis tout le monde le fait
mais ce qui a mon avis remplacé la chose
c'est la pornographie tout le monde le
fait aussi mais on ne s'envente pas
encore
comment vous voyez ces évolutions de la
sexualité en même temps moi j'ai pas
l'impression qu'il y ait de réel
évolution parce que toutes les pratiques
sexuelles elles ont toujours existé sauf
peut-être qu'on en parlait moins on en
parlait pas où c'était plus tabou et là
c'est rendu public par une société qui
est avide aussi de de témoignages de
vidéos pornographiques etc mais toutes
ces pratiques sexuelles on a rien
inventé aujourd'hui que ce soit la
sexualité ou bien tout tout ce qui est
tout ce qui peut exister mais en fait
moi aussi je suis assez mitigé parce que
j'ai l'impression aussi qu'il y a
justement derrière une grande injonction
en particulier à travers la pornographie
pour les femmes et en particulier pour
les jeunes filles qui pensent que si on
n'a pas fait un certain nombre de
pratiques sexuelles
on n'est pas en fait on ne va pas faire
plaisir à l'homme on va pas être connu
comme comme une femme parce que il y a
aussi un rapport je pense à
l'adolescence entre sexualité et
identité qui est très très fort est-ce
que vous voulez dire qu'il y a un
prosélytisme en quelque sorte de ces
pratiques là oui il y a la chanson de
Brassens qui faisait l'éloge de la jeune
fille qui reste pucelle pourquoi pas
enfin je veux dire aujourd'hui c'est un
certain âge on n'est pas entré dans la
sexualité on n'est pas considéré par ses
pairs comme comme dans le coup quoi en
fait on est arriéré on reste encore
enfantin on n'est pas complètement
adulte donc moi je pense qu'il doit pas
y avoir
d'injonctions surtout pensez que la
société aujourd'hui pousse à ce que les
gens consomment que tous les tous les
modes sexuels exactement et surtout pour
les pour les filles ou je pense aussi il
y a une certaine forme d'effraction qui
reprend le teint psychanalytique c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose que quand
on est un homme enfin ça dépend des
pratiques sexuelles mais et donc il y a
il y a un certain tout d'un coup parfois
elle doivent faire énormément de choses
alors qu'elles n'entre pas dans une dans
une où elles vont elles vont connaître
leur corps et des pratiques sexuelles
progressivement et je pense que ça peut
être assez traumatisant il y a une
réelle injonction à ça et d'ailleurs on
voit que même dans les dans mes 68 était
considérées comme une libération mais il
y a beaucoup de femmes aussi derrière il
y avait quand même encore un patriarcat
une demande des hommes qui jouissaient
en fait de ces corps féminins qui
étaient plus libres mais où les femmes
elles-mêmes n'avaient pas toujours en
fait ne trouvez pas
à ce niveau de la discussion est-ce
qu'on peut parler distinctement d'une
sexualité féminine et d'une sexualité
masculine ou est-ce que finalement c'est
des conduites indistinctes
et vous me regardez
sur le fait ce que vous venez de dire il
y a rien de nouveau sous le soleil il y
en a pas inventé sauf des choses très
très particulière oui par exemple dans
le monde gay il y a des pratiques très
spéciales mais la sexualité des couples
elle est tout simplement certainement
plus libre que nos arrières
grands-parents elle est il n'y a pas la
promiscuité ou la gêne et tant mieux
pour cela par contre il y a alors il y a
deux mouvements c'est vrai que tout le
monde tout le mouvement des études sur
le genre amènerait l'idée
qui ne doit pas y avoir qu'il n'y a pas
de distinction
qu'ils ne doivent pas y en avoir sur
tout à fait d'accord c'est à dire que
qu'il y ait autant de d'égalité de
parité de entre garçons filles il y a
des différences et il y a de fortes
différences
notamment c'est vrai que la sexualité
masculine qui semble très pulsionnelle
très et la moi j'aimais bien une phrase
de Lucie garage qui est une grande
féministe des années 70 qui dit ceci la
femme a des sexes un peu partout elle
peut jouir d'un peu partout et c'est
très vrai je mettrai en parallèle et ça
c'est de moi pour le pour faire un
parallèle l'homme n'a un sexe presque au
niveau génital je caricature pas c'est
là que nous avons le plus de sensations
et il ne sait pas trop en jouir
autrement le jeu quand même si on parle
d'hétérosexualité serait que chacun
apprenne que le Régis de l'autre est
assez différent et là un homme va
s'ouvrir à une sexualité autre quand on
reste dans ce type de stéréotypes qui
sont millénaires bien cette semaine des
échecs Magalie sur cette différence
entre les deux je suis tout à fait les
propos de Philippe Reynaud parce que je
pense qu'il y a un orgasme global
Freud parler de pansexualité à l'époque
en disant que le corps était rempli de
zones érogènes donc potentiellement
excitable de diverses parties du corps
chez les femmes on a tout de suite vu
qu'il y avait un clivage entre l'orgasme
dit vaginal je dis vaginale parce qu'il
a été déconstruit aujourd'hui et
l'orgasme clitoridien or les femmes on
sait peuvent jouir de plusieurs endroits
du corps des dessins notamment des
tétons etc l'homme lui on a parlé
d'orgasme pénien effectivement parce que
c'est l'endroit du corps le plus le plus
énervé et et jouit principalement de ces
parties génitales mais il peut aussi
jouir d'autres partie du corps
la communauté homosexuelle le dit depuis
très longtemps aujourd'hui les créateurs
d'accessoires de sextoys le savent très
bien parce qu'ils vendent énormément de
sextoys intimes masculin qui concerne le
point prostatique la prostate chez
l'homme est un des endroits qui peut
apporter un plaisir un plaisir diffus
donc ça ça chamboule ça bouleverse toute
la construction imaginaire de l'orgasme
masculin parce que du coup l'homme peut
devenir aussi polyorgasmique
Strauss vous voulez d'écouter ce qui
vient d'être dit des orgasmes sur
différentes parties du corps
le corps
excitable à différents niveaux pour
l'homme la femme est-ce qu'il y a pas
une forme de banalisation du rapport
sexuel tel qu'on le concevait
classiquement et quelles conséquences ça
peut avoir à votre avis
qui vous permettez quand même là aussi
un petit rappel de Freud c'est à la fin
de l'article sur la zone homosexuelle ou
c'est très frappant de voir le
l'extraordinaire distance l'absent de
jugement moral de Freud sur le
homosexualité et il considère que
l'homosexualité n'est pas un problème
pour la psychanalyse elle doit rendre
compte du mode de soin d'objet mais elle
n'a pas en juger et il explique que il y
a les très physiques sexuelles homme
femme
anatomique les trepsychiques et le mode
de soin d'objet et les trois peuvent se
combiner les positions psychiques
peuvent être masculines ou féminines
chez un homme comme chez une femme au
sens organique et l'objet peut être
homme ou femme ça fait pour chacun
quatre positions possibles déjà et donc
Freud laisse entendre qu'il a une
position féminine distincte
ensuite il est lu dans 10 ans ça a
quelque chose avec la passivité
l'homme l'activité là quand le reprend
et le formules est vraiment le théorise
comme l'accès pour tous les parents pour
tous les êtres humains l'accès possible
à une jouissance autre il y a la
jouissance effectivement
physique pénienne ou clitoridienne la
jouissance disons apaisante celle qui
détend qui les contracte de la
masturbation ou de la pénétration du
coït et il y a quand même plus
facilement accessible pour les femmes
une jouissance autre qui avoir est
effectivement avec l'amour avec la
spiritualité et c'est un développement
de la position très assurée de Freud de
la bisexualité
constitutionnelle de l'être humain
et vous encore une portière vous êtes
par rapport à ça oui alors moi je suis
d'accord avec cette idée de bisexualité
psychique bien sûr qui a été avancé par
des psychanalystes mais pas d'abord par
Freud si il me semble bien et ça me
semble très important en effet que cette
idée que ce qui a été dit avant c'est à
dire que en fait homme ou femme en fait
on a tous un corps qui est
potentiellement complètement érogène il
passe seulement au niveau des organes
sexuels sauf que les femmes en fait sont
été aussi élevées dans cette dans ce
rapport et elles ont aussi un sexe
anatomique et du côté de la réceptivité
mais qui aussi peut être pris aussi
d'une autre façon tout ça une question
de représentation donc en fait je pense
qu'il y a un une inhibition du côté du
masculin du fait de l'éducation et
inconsciente à percevoir aussi son corps
comme potente potentiellement réceptif
de même que la femme peut être aussi
complètement active donc en fait je
pense que c'est plutôt des inhibitions
culture naturel et sociales et que là à
mon avis c'est complètement un mythe
depuis l'antiquité de penser que les
femmes ont super orgasme voilà aussi tel
que le disait là quand voilà absolument
insasia parce que ça participe aussi de
l'idée que les femmes sont plus
sexuelles aussi que les hommes et ont
une sorte d'incessabilité de même que
l'hystérie renvoyait aussi
étymologiquement à ça au fait qu'elles
sont toujours elles sont elles ont
besoin d'avoir qu'on leur remplisse le
vent ou qu'on leur remplisse le sexe
donc il y a en même temps je pense qu'il
faut faire le tri entre des
représentations
psychanalytiques qui sont extrêmement
pertinentes pour envisager ces processus
sexuels qui sont avant tout des
processus pas de pratique sexuelle mais
qui sont avant tout une psychose
sexualité c'est avant tout dans la tête
la sexualité et en même temps aussi
faire le tri entre des représentations
aussi j'enrées de l'orgasme féminin et
c'est vraiment je pense que en fait on
peut on a à peu près le même orgasme et
tout ça c'est des constructions sociales
merci
[Musique]
alors loue Andréa Salomé dit je ne peux
conformer ma vie à des modèles alors
s'émanciper des modèles peut conduire
dans ce cas-là à une pratique une
culture consumériste de la sexualité
jouir de son corps sans l'inscrire dans
une relation à l'être aimé je cite roll
en bas est-ce que c'est toujours de la
sexualité Philippe Bruno mais je trouve
que votre question
permet de d'élever ce qu'on vient de
dire parce que tout à l'heure j'ai eu
l'impression en parlant de différence
par exemple homme femme de ramener trop
génital c'est pas ça du tout la
sexualité et c'est vrai que c'était
ça oui et non parce que je veux dire
chaque fois qu'en définitive la vraie
dimension de la sexualité c'est
lorsqu'elle on le transcende parce que
il y a à la fois bien sûr ce qui se
passe physiquement dans dans cette
excitation pulsionnelle dans la
résolution des tensions mais la
sexualité c'est la relation je dirais à
deux
et je vais vous donner une phrase
amusante parce que que je dis souvent
une passion parce que cette espèce
d'idées aujourd'hui vous évoquez on
parle trop des pratiques plus pratiques
elles existent on peut les et puis nous
permettez-moi que vous précisiez quelque
chose vous dites que la sexualité comme
Roland Barthe c'est la relation à deux
est-ce que la sexualité c'est la
relation avec un jouet ou par exemple
autre chose de virtuel bien sûr parce
que dans ce jouet vous pourrez ça
devient un autre très souvent dans mon
éloge de la masturbation je l'ai dit
exactement comme ça s'il est très rare
qu'on ne fantasme pas un partenaire
potentiel une situation qu'on a vécue et
ainsi de suite qui va souvent aider au
niveau fantasmatique mais simplement
pour revenir sur cette idée des
pratiques
la sexualité pour moi elle est beaucoup
plus large entre deux personnes quel que
soit l'orientation
très souvent vous avez cette histoire
alors des pratiques il y a le génital
dans on a parlé et puis on me demande et
les préliminaires et alors je dis par
exemple je vais poser ça lorsque je vois
un couple je vais vous poser une
question très directe je vous la pose à
tous les trois quatre
quel temps doivent avoir les
préliminaires alors vous avez des gens
qui disent ça doit faire 30 minutes ça
fait ça fait 10 ça fait
je dis mais au moins 8 jours
lorsque je dis cela pour leur faire
comprendre c'est à dire si pendant huit
jours vous êtes dans une relation où il
y a les conditions de l'amour et ça ça
vous regarde c'est ça regarde de l'un et
l'autre dans leur imaginaire dans leur
pratique dans leur vécu à ce moment-là
peut-être qu'il peut se passer on s'en
fiche peut-être qu'il peut se passer
quelque chose d'intime et sur plein de
modèles il se passerait quelque chose
mais vous croyez pas qu'on est dans
l'abstraction par rapport à tous les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent ils
se disent mais finalement la sexualité
c'est quasiment tout simplement sexuel
vous écoutez on a l'impression qu'à
l'extrême vous avez raison parce que à
l'extrait
oui et je trouve ça formidable lorsqu'on
a pendant huit jours une relation qui
est qui est extraordinaire ou qui plaît
mutuellement
peu importe le mode de réalisation qu'il
aura et à l'extrême il peut ne pas y
avoir ni pénétration puisque c'est ça
qui va poser le plus des difficultés à
la fois aux uns et aux autres mais c'est
pas pour l'éviter il peut y avoir des
jouissances de ce moment vous entendez
mais j'aimerais que chacun s'exprime
parce que c'est une question essentielle
pour les jeunes générations voir les
seniors pour vous marchent trop il peut
y avoir abstraction de l'être aimé sous
forme d'un fantasme par exemple il peut
y avoir des sexualités plus
pulsionnelles tu as entendu que
pulsionnel ça veut pas dire animal ou
strictement génital c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est lié à des images
des empreintes précoces de la vie cela
dit voilà aussi pour prendre un petit
peu
on voit un peu différente je dirais que
la sexualité c'est à 3 c'est la relation
de soi à soi avec un ou deux partenaires
la relation de soi parce que la relation
de soi de ses propres représentations de
soi-même avec sa jouissance et quelque
chose d'extraordinairement compliqué
c'est là le bricolage et là il y a deux
modes de bricolage il y a le bricolage
qui évoque londréa c'est la dimension
transgressive et fractive d'infraction
de la sexualité qui est toujours
présente d'une façon ou d'une autre il y
a toujours quelque chose qui est aux
limites de la loi de l'interdit de la
transgression il y a cette sexualité là
qui est partagée par les hommes et par
les femmes qui est le génital et puis il
y a une sexualité autre qui est hors
transgression Daloa cette dite sexualité
féminine qui est en mode de jouissance
que vous contestez peut-être je sais pas
mais qui semble-t-il existe
elle peut aussi être masculine mais
c'est plus difficile la candidan
joliment que l'homme est affligé il
écrit avec un pH affligé de l'organe
donc ça fait écran pour lui à l'accès à
cette jouissance que cliniquement
certaines femmes décrivent et qui en
général disons le quand même fou la
trouille elle fout la trouille aux
hommes et aux femmes elles-mêmes parce
que là justement on peut pas la ranger
dans l'infraction on ne peut rien en
dire oui justement
[Musique]
il peut aussi voilà il peut y avoir une
circulation de ce qui est considéré
comme masculin et féminin au sein même
du rapport sexuel et entre activités
réceptivité sans qu'il y ait toujours un
clivage une séparation qui qui est
souvent d'ailleurs frustrante pour l'un
comme pour l'autre qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez Magalie crozicalisto oui la
première chose il y a certains courants
féministes actuellement je crois que
c'est Barbara lonzy qui essaye de
réformer la psychanalyse avec le phallus
par l'importance du clitoris aussi comme
clitoris en tant que phallus et
la visibilité du clitoris aujourd'hui
permettrait de repenser éventuellement
certains certaines constructions
psychanalytique clairement de l'accès à
la sexualité mais sinon moi ce que
j'observe notamment au cabinet de
consultation et dans toutes nos
statistiques actuelles c'est qu'il y a
depuis quelques années une
dégénitalisation des rapports et est-ce
que c'est un progrès alors ça évolution
n'est pas un progrès comme toute pour
qu'une innovation soit innovation il
faut qu'elle soit une adhésion dans le
temps long ce qu'on voit c'est que la
demande de beaucoup de femmes
aujourd'hui la première demande en
cabinet de consultation c'est pour une
hypo libido une baisse de désir quand on
creuse un petit peu on leur pose des
questions quel est ce désir manquant de
quoi vous n'avez pas envie on voit qu'il
s'agit souvent infinie de la pénétration
et si on donne comme exercice
sexologique on est dans du concret là du
mathématiques ce qu'on appelle le Sunset
focus que Masters et Johnson avait lancé
dans les années 60 de dire essayer des
rapports ensemble avec l'interdit de la
pénétration le désir revient oui mais
interdire la pénétration c'est mettre en
cause la reproduction est-ce que il faut
que ça puisse exister aussi la
reproduction alors bien sûr mais on
parle justement il faut pas mélanger les
choses est-ce qu'on parlez pas non plus
exclure qu'il y a une jouissance il y a
une jouissance dans la pénétration alors
bien sûr que beaucoup de femmes
éprouvent de la jouissance pendant la
reconnaissez évidemment simplement
beaucoup se sentent être en devoir de
répondre aux désirs de leur partenaire
et à ce moment-là
et de réponse à donner et si une
personne se sent dans un devoir de
réponse c'est un anti libido donc il
faut casser ce système là pour voir
s'extraire de de ce système pour avoir
des échanges de désir et ça en passe
parfois par le pas de côté vis-à-vis de
la pénétration pendant quelques temps et
on voit que des choses se libèrent pour
beaucoup de femmes une question précise
là je voudrais
mais en cause les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui les jeunes mais pas que pas
un temps infini devant des écrans les
violences s'étales qu'est-ce que vous
pensez d'une cybersexualité c'est à dire
faire l'amour avec un écran pour trouver
est-ce que c'est une perversion ou pas
alors l'écran est un médium c'est pas
faire l'amour avec un écran exactement
derrière en général soit il y a une
personne soit il y a des images on voit
que avec la pandémie cette cette
cybersexualité s'est déployée soit parce
que des couples étaient à distance et
souhaitaient avoir des rapports amoureux
à distance ça leur a permis les
personnes se retrouveront seules ce soit
davantage inscrits sur les réseaux de
rencontres on a ça aussi et il y a donc
une nouvelle modalisation de la
sexualité qui en passe par l'écran le
cybersexe c'est comme le mois cyborg
dans notre société il est en train
d'être pas mal étudié en France la
France est un peu à la pointe de ça avec
notamment Serge Tisseron Frédéric
cordeau il y a des études concrètes on
voit que le cybersexe se passe dans un
monde donc numérique il peut y avoir des
endroits des sites spécifiques ou les
personnes vont via un avatar donc un
mois cyborg le mois c'est une identité
numérique et via cet avatar vont
ressentir des choses
sont génitalisation ça active le circuit
de récompense et il peut y avoir des
orgasmes aussi par écran interposé
évidemment est-ce que c'est charnel
cette cyber sexualité ah ben c'est
forcément le charnel puisque ça se passe
par notamment cette réalisation
orgasique tout le temps c'est à dire que
on est devant quelque chose de compliqué
qui s'est passé avec depuis 20 ans
depuis les années 2000 avec la
multiplication des images des sites
pornos ok il faut savoir l'une de mes
études de l'un de mes étudiants a fait
un travail à quelques années
sur en essayant de voir le flux internet
du porno et le premier consommateur
devant les sites marchands
au monde entier c'est à dire qu'en
définitive il y a une utilisation
en deux en dehors de nos pays
occidentaux c'est pour certains le seul
moyen d'accès alors des hommes en très
grande majorité à une image d'excitation
la majorité des hommes ont besoin d'une
image d'excitation beaucoup de femmes
sont plus dans le monde fantasmatique et
peuvent y arriver facilement et à partir
de là il y a vraiment moi je crois
quelque chose de compliqué qui est une
dépendance qui peut être à ce mode
d'excitation ça pourrait mal envoyer
là-dessus vous dites cette chose là mais
quand on voit les sites de rencontres
les sites
sexuels qui on vous envoie des mails
sans arrêt vous pouvez avoir la plus
belle fille du monde etc ils sont tous
basés
sur la relation sexuelle ils sont pas
basés sur des orgasmes qui pourraient se
produire de la plante du pied jusqu'aux
cheveux alors c'est comment vous
expliquez cette chose là c'est vrai
qu'on a aujourd'hui quand même et il est
difficile pour la plupart des gens
d'imaginer un couple qui est pas une
réalisation sexuelle épanouie c'est
quand même c'est les images de la
société qui ont changé moi je conseille
beaucoup
que ce soit à travers les sites que ce
soit par l'utilisation du porno que ça
soit fait de façon soft ça peut se faire
de temps en temps sinon c'est vrai que
l'addiction à cela va amener quelque
chose de très compliqué avec soi et
ensuite dans la relation qu'on peut
avoir avec les autres mais comme
intermédiaire les relations dans la
société par exemple pour se rencontrer
puisqu'on a des tranches de vie il va y
avoir beaucoup de rencontres au fil de
la vie c'est pas très facile c'est les
sites peuvent y aider très bien mais
conseil aux auditeurs vous vous très
courtement des contacts des chats très
vite ou patients vous vous rencontrez
vous voyez si ça vous intéresse mais
passez longtemps là-dessus on est devant
des choses qui sont compliquées j'ai on
a vu combien de fois des couples qui
ensuite n'arrivent plus à séparer et qui
sont extrêmement mal ensemble alors
cybersexualité qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez marche Strauss c'est des
facilités de la masturbation et la
masturbation ne date pas d'hier alors
effectivement
il y avait les graviaux grivoises
quelqu'un a dit la deuxième photographie
jamais faite au monde a dû être une
photo pornographique c'est assez
astucieux je trouve je sais pas si c'est
vrai et puis maintenant c'est à portée
de main c'est si je puis dire
c'est la mise en scène des fantasmes
c'est sûr que d'être confronté à une
scène sexuelle est en soi transgressif
et donc excitant et ensuite on a le
catalogue des choix préférentiels
jusqu'au moment où ça s'épuise
évidemment
que là aussi la sexualité libérée sans
entrave sans la dimension transgressive
ça finit par produire de l'ennui ou
alors une forme d'addiction qui
effectivement coupe de la recherche du
lien à l'autre mais c'est une autre
affaire la sexualité avec un partenaire
ne se limite pas la masturbation pas du
tout et on voit bien quand même
les jeunes dont on parle comme ça il y a
quand même une chose qui les préoccupe
beaucoup beaucoup c'est l'amour il
continue à chercher à vouloir l'amour et
la fidélité la prolifération du porno
n'y change rien
[Musique]
on va maintenant parler de certaines
déviations parce que c'est il y a eu de
nombreux ouvrages je pense à celui de
Camille Kushner de Vanessa springora
maintenant un ouvrage d'Hélène de Vinc
dans un livre qui s'appelle l'impunité
elle dénonce le comportement sexuel d'un
homme célèbre Patrick Poivre d'Arvor en
l'occurrence mais qui en vertu des
dispositions du code de procédure pénale
bénéficie de la présomption d'innocence
cela dit ce qui est en cause et sa
rejoindre notre débat c'est le sentiment
de toute puissance le rapport d'ultra
domination de celui qui s'arroche le
pouvoir pour imposer un rapport sexuel
est-ce que vous pensez souhaitable et
réalisable que la justice soit plus
prête à condamner tous les prédateurs
sexuels quel que soit leur notoriété
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez Corinne
Fortier mais certainement
enfin c'est ça me semble complètement
évident et la France est en retard par
rapport à énormément de pays en
particulier d'Europe du Nord je pense à
la Suède etc ou ses comportements sont
habituels encore aujourd'hui dans toutes
les sphères du pouvoir que ce soit
intellectuel artistique
cinématographique
scientifiques hospitalier etc donc en
fait c'est des c'est des abus du pouvoir
qui participent du patriarcat et souvent
les pédophiles peuvent avoir des
pratiques autant avec des petits garçons
et des petites filles et pourquoi c'est
justement parce que en fait ces enfants
qui sont avant l'adolescence ils sont
pas ils sont quasiment pas sexueux et
pour eux c'est des anges presque
peut-être pour les pour les non non mais
non c'est vrai je pense que la question
de l'adolescence et de la puberté elle
elle donne une sexuelle si on c'est à
dire qu'elle rend masculin et féminin si
vous voyez souvent des pédophiles en
tout cas je pense pas je pense à ceux de
l'église ils ont ils touchent aussi bien
ils abusent aussi bien des petits
garçons que des une fille
indistinctement donc c'est quelque chose
étant donné les traumas que ça laisse
derrière soi la difficulté à avoir une
sexualité après dans sa vie la
difficulté à être en couple d'être
traumatismes qui restent à vie bien sûr
que ils doivent être condamnés et
souvent ils le sont pas il reste dans
leur fonction
et la France est vraiment très très en
retard je voudrais prolonger cette
discussion en disant que ceux qui
utilisent la toute puissance
pour avoir des rapports ou des supposés
rapports sexuels est-ce que ça avoir
quelque part avec une pulsion de mort
utilisez cette chose là c'est en tout
cas effectivement une
c'est prédateur je suis d'accord avec
votre terme dans la mesure justement où
il y a la dimension pulsionnelle là
encore une fois il faut préciser qu'une
seule année ça veut dire fantasmatique
ça veut dire c'est déjà une construction
bricolée une image et par exemple le
journaliste célèbre dont vous parlez
il y a un côté assez misérable dans les
témoignages qui viennent de tous les
côtés l'image que ça évoque mais c'est
pour moi une strictement pour moi c'est
celle du coq du village du coq du
village d'antan qui qui sur son tas de
fumier et qui de temps en temps soit sur
une poule et je vous assure que j'ai vu
des patients qui ont été élevés à la
campagne et pour lesquels cette image du
coq du village a eu une dimension tout à
fait pregnante dans leur vie d'adulte
donc là il y a un côté pathétique à la
fois prédateur mais pathétique parce
qu'elle l'ignorance de du consentement
de l'eau de l'autre comme sujet capable
de dire quelque chose alors que dans les
histoires il faut quand même les
différencier l'histoire de Dieu Amel
Duhamel c'est pas taper tous les petits
garçons du village et Camille Kouchner
raconte bien comment elle se marie tout
le monde était heureux et c'était un
endroit merveilleux enchanté et c'est un
homme qui avait tout il avait tout le
pouvoir l'argent l'A aux femmes et il a
été obligé de s'inventer une saloperie
quand même quand même pour arriver à
bander ce qui montre si vous permettez
ce qui illustre une remarque de Lacan
qui dit que les riches ont beaucoup de
mal à bander bien pour finir pour quand
même pour finir sur matinef bathnaf
pédophilie prédateur certainement
puisqu'il prend les enfants comme des
objets de son fantasme il se préoccupe
pas de savoir si ça leur fait du mal
mais c'est pas de chance pour lui c'est
pas de chance pour un homme ça arrive
souvent aux hommes plutôt d'avoir un
fantasme unique et prévalent qui leur
est nécessaire pour l'exercice de leur
sexualité tout à fait alors je voudrais
devant cette citation célèbre savoir ce
que vous pensez
fibronneux et Magali Crozet Callisto que
les violeurs
sont des mâles qui ont du mal à bander
est-ce que d'abord dans l'absolu les
violeurs sont pas que des mâles il y a
mais en très grande majorité
est-ce que vous diriez vous reprenez
cette idée que il viole parce qu'ils ont
une sexualité misérable et qui ont des
ont du mal à bander oui mais quand je
dirais misérable parce qu'il y a
misérabilisme mais je veux pas faire les
exonérés de quoi que ce soit c'est vous
comprenez c'est
cette inimaginable inacceptable et le
gros problème on a beaucoup parlé de
consentement c'est pas acceptable que ça
se poursuive
c'est pas acceptable non plus qu'il y
ait prescription
la grande difficulté je vous ai dit tout
à l'heure après avoir j'avais écrit un
article où parce que en tant
qu'anthropologue physique moi j'aime
beaucoup travailler avec des chimpanzés
gorilles orants il n'y a pas d'inceste
chez les grands primates de nous venons
pour une raison très simple c'est qu'à
la puberté les petites femelles vont
vivre dans un autre groupe qui a inventé
ça elle rencontra jamais le père ou le
frère ok où les frères il se trouve que
l'humanité et alors qu'il y a ce qu'on
appelle les zoologues appellent ça
l'évitement de l'inceste les vêtements
de la science existe aussi chez les
félins enfin peu importe en passant
l'humanité la fragilité de la
transmission ça a été le langage depuis
notre enfance c'est ce qu'on a entendu
des interdits on les entend pas
traditionnellement ça se disait beaucoup
plus et bien aujourd'hui le problème de
l'impres presque de la prescriptibilité
ça se heurte à quelque chose de
d'important dans nos sociétés c'est que
la société peut être rédemptrice mais là
on peut s'interroger moi l'artifice que
j'avais trouvé c'était que c'était comme
le crime pour l'humanité qui est la
seule raison d'un prescriptibilité c'est
qu'en fait on touchait à l'humanité de
l'enfant en train de se construire il
nous reste très peu de temps Magalie
Crozet Callisto est-ce que dans votre
cabinet de sexologue vous entendez ce
genre d'homme remarque les riches ont du
mal à bander c'est pour ça qu'il y a des
viols j'entends pas forcément ce genre
de remarque vous l'entendez vous alors
ça pose une question aujourd'hui c'est
faire fi aussi de tous les adjuvants à
la sexualité notamment médicamenteux
maintenant
la question se pose beaucoup moins
puisque les hommes peuvent avoir recours
très facilement
à partir d'une ordonnance aux adjuvants
sexuels donc c'est à dire pour être en
érection donc déjà ça tient ça tient
moins et puis moi j'aimerais revenir
aussi sur ce que fait livrer nos disait
je pense aussi vraiment que la
prescriptibilité dans notre société et
quelque chose qui ne permet pas la
parole des
êtres qui ont été agressés aujourd'hui
elle est elle a été reculer un petit peu
donc je crois que c'est de 30 ans à
partir de 18 ans mais il n'empêche c'est
aussi faire fi de tout ce mécanisme de
si quelqu'un voter enfant doit être
condamné au quatrième âge et bien oui il
doit faire face à ces actes il y a une
loi il y a une loi dans nos pays et face
à certains types de comportements comme
les prédateurs c'est le rappel à la loi
uniquement le rappel à la loi souvent
qui permet de prendre une prise de
conscience pour eux parce que ça les
protège aussi eux-mêmes donc oui c'est
important vous êtes d'accord avec ça
encore une forte
curs enfin des systèmes hormonals qui
permettent de bloquer l'érection de ces
hommes ce qui ne permet pas et leur
pulsions mais comment les reconnaître
déjà avant justement il faut qu'il
comment voulez-vous justement la
question c'est que il soit accusé et
pour ça il faut qu'il y ait cette
libération de la parole qui a commencé
avec Mewtwo mais qui est vraiment
balbutiante moi je dirais pas qu'on est
complètement libéré que les femmes et on
le voit d'ailleurs il y a toujours des
difficultés puisque ces hommes sont
toujours protégés ils savent il faut
voir aussi comment la mitalisation même
de je trouve calme lorsque il a il a eu
ce cette il a abusé cette femme là dans
un hôtel aux États-Unis tout le monde
disait oui c'est un grand homme il a pas
pu faire ça etc c'est à dire que tout de
suite on est on est dans des logiques
aussi de réseau aussi souvent assez
masculiniste mais pas que de protection
d'une d'un pouvoir ou finalement la
parole des femmes est écrasée on va dire
ah bah elle va être diabolisée on va
dire ah bah elle a cherché pourquoi
est-ce qu'elle est rentrée dans sa
chambre elle avait une robe une jupe
voilà donc c'est à dire que souvent les
femmes en plus encore aujourd'hui on
sait qu'elles sont on va terminer si
vous voulez là-dessus en un mot si le
consentement finalement dans une
relation n'est qu'une présomption de
consentement finalement que valent les
mots dans ce cas là qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez marche trop sur la très peu de
temps pour conclure là-dessus je pense
que
évidemment la prise en compte du
consentement de du de la partenaire et
fondamental ça va de soi l'autre est
aussi un sujet mais encore une fois
l'autre n'est pas dans la sexualité
l'autre n'est pas qu'un sujet et là il y
a toutes les zones griffes du
consentement l'appareillage discursif la
soumission des femmes le fait on dit oui
pour faire plaisir parce qu'on peut pas
dire non enfin
grise mais quand même il y a une zone
qui n'est pas grise c'est effectivement
la perversion ou l'autre est vraiment
pris comme objet autrement dit céder
n'est pas consentir reste à savoir
agit pour mattheneff la swing aura il y
avait une histoire d'amour entre eux
aussi et ce qui complique encore les
choses ça a craqué quand elle s'est
aperçue en fait qu'elle n'était que
objet du fait de sa jeunesse et qu'elle
n'était pas aussi aimée qu'elle pensait
bien ben écoutez on va terminer si vous
voulez là-dessus je vais vous présenter
une bibliographie alors Magalie Crozet
Callisto vous avez publié récemment
presque récemment sa date de quelques
mois les révolutions de l'orgasme
Magalie Crozet Callisto est-ce qu'on
peut dire que ce livre permet aux gens
de voir l'étendue
ubiquitaire de l'orgasme on nous
accepteriez ça on parlait de l'éventail
du sexe donc là c'est l'éventail de
l'orgasme je crois j'espère Hélène de
Wingles dont j'ai cité l'ouvrage et qui
s'appelle impunité qui est sorti au
seuil et je également signaler que
Magali Crozet Callisto a mis en ligne un
podcast qui s'appelle naturellement
orgasmia les coulisses de la jouissance
on voudrait signaler cette revue
psychanalyse yétu dans lequel il y a un
intérêt pour ce domaine de l'éventail du
sexe et auquel a contribué Corinne
Fortier dont je signale qu'elle a publié
un ouvrage qui s'appelle le corps de
l'identité et qui est publié chez
cartala je voudrais également signaler
deux ouvrages du docteur Philippe Brenot
à la fois pourquoi c'est si compliqué
l'amour mais aussi une BD
sur l'incroyable histoire du sexe tous
les deux publiés aux arènes c'est une BD
extrêmement réussie et je voudrais
signaler de marstrauss la presse du
temps aux éditions nouvelles du chant la
gagnant la presse du temps c'est quoi la
presse du temps c'est ça c'est que dans
les la Constitution subjective le temps
qui a une place fondamentale c'est une
thèse de Lacan et de la crise un article
en 45 là-dessus qui le fondement de
toute son œuvre et c'est un commentaire
de de cet article essentiellement pas
uniquement loin de là il est question
aussi de la jeune homosexuelle mais je
on est assez loin de la sexualité merci
mesdames merci messieurs d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci à
l'équipe de LCP qui va à la réaliser et
je voudrais avant de vous quitter vous
soumettre cette citation
la sexuation est une décision
s'inscrivant dans une filiation qui
respecte l'altérité comme fondement du
couple sans cette altérité le sexe est
hors lieu c'est une citation de Pierre
Bruno
[Musique]